so I mean you can smash me all you want
please
[Laughter]
you should cartoony looking [ __ ] are
you a short little Jar Jar Binks that's
what you look like you know what right
now so I could calm that I think say
Matt [ __ ]
I know he's got a [ __ ] body but a little
dig I can guarantee you that I said
echoing is at Steve's TV or I think I
know nothing did you gonna do nothing
all right
oh my god why what are you gonna do
Fabiana show tonight ah totally [ __ ]
up here what are you gonna do crack but
nothing I'll buy you a steak dinner your
money at least oh yeah give me the
restaurant okay I'm gonna start
twitching and then Griffin can you quit
out once I start
a lot of your first line you need I mean
I'm trying to find a plane good at all
okay all right so Steve's TV on I think
so I think you're - yeah yeah yeah oh
there was a van that man saw you I do
that again I think it went away
yeah yeah
you know I don't even know we're just
we're gonna start a game when Koch gets
in when everybody's ready let's just
play I guess just me for now
yeah people have questions for us are we
using that some other time I know you
can do the V everybody actually Bobby
all right I love you Bobby
well you should see love Z they say they
love you you shall father love you tiger
Bailey this week are you going to talk
about is Eric going on tiger belly I
just closed the door and left
sorry guys here just showing me a little
bit of Far Cry yeah yeah damn we have to
watch Eric shitty game play and not coax
question no I'm straight
we got we get a water smashing right
yeah Colin Bobby you're not gonna pick
up put it on speaker be good for the
cast on speaker
Stevie joining yeah I'm logging into the
menu right now Bobby yeah so I gotta
come on target barely do well you just
make a special you know a very special
Tiger belly if you would on a Tuesday
[Music]
you know I'm gonna see Barack Obama
would never be on Tiger Bell Brendo
thank God thought I had to watch Eric
well you are watching Eric and a
different Eric but in Eric number well
we can't we can't all foreplay or unless
we do like mayhem or something right I
can get out here we do coke in here for
ya bro but we could do it because we can
no no I want to see the Craig versus
Steve matchup all right hey we should
have a tournament we should have Craig
birth Steve and then Griffin verse
Pikachu and then the winner of beats
faces each other okay whatever
right while you get the past cuz you're
the best
I mean yeah he gets the first round bye
Steve how about me and Craig versus coke
I think me and Craig could do it how
about how about this come on three
verse me and Pikachu I'm gonna make you
leader weekend so I okay what what not
Steve you get whatever can you guys make
a tweet or whatever saying we're live
now I guess Oh distance yours distant
shores just okay oh yeah
social media manager yeah let me let me
see a tweet out here I'm gonna I'm gonna
put the the worst fire team tag though
cuz I want everybody yeah yeah yes the
come on make a post what is that to do
make it a pose I'll do an instant video
I'll do instead video okay yeah is it
just worse fire team is that what's
worse fire team ever yeah okay huh okay
hey Pikachu you're going down you're not
gonna beat the social media manager I
like that I like when cherish was asking
you about being the social media manager
that was so so Nathanael says like
Daniel Nathanael yeah
all right night sweetie
yeah I did a story I did a story hole
awesome yeah all right yeah yeah well do
class will do their little sources all
right all right so let's go inch bottom
Stevie present me and and rb/o
distance or all right we got this all
right pizza so we got we've got a 2v1
or we can't go one-on-one with Coco Coco
would kill us with those pistols there
we got we got our head I didn't go I
didn't go to the fights um I just watch
it oh he's got that oh you're gonna risk
runner
let's go son bunch of story much of
souls about to show you just saying come
on we got this we're not fine suck it up
stash our wet sure yeah yeah
we take out call em pikachu's easy hey
crazy [ __ ] yeah the Steve was buried
Steve go to the cave somebody said they
want as they love you oh well never mind
just control all right Pikachu let's go
yeah let's [ __ ] up on you there - all
right
I hate all of them okay yeah me too stay
here come over here we're gonna hold
this area where I'm at
he's gonna go for heavy so what he's not
happy right here we got a heavy right
here gonna use that sleeper simulant oh
I know what that guy says they come
there how many times are you killed
Pikachu how many time watch out behind
you
oh my god
no but he's Pikachu's in front of me
that's trying to get there are you guys
I'm not what running
[Applause]
he's got that [ __ ] rift they peek me
I get together get together [ __ ]
they're flanking
leave her
yes okay I got it here
[ __ ] out of here just fusion thunder oh
[ __ ] am i messing up the camera I'm
coming coffee
I kept this for coke he's hurt though
[Music]
yes okay
Oh God shotgun ammo
get back up damn it why am i fighting
this and what am i fighting a two-on-one
where's my other two guys we're behind
you but you ran out there
he's got shock because that's where they
are oh my god each other and I'm
fighting two on one right there is
okay my seller take this [ __ ] all
right beats boom nice great okay come
and go stay together you can't kill us
all coming I need help with coke don't
spend all that ammo in one place can we
go together after them team shot Craig
you're literally the word player like I
like now I see what the problem is you
shot this guy hello you just heavy
together
[Laughter]
watch out for that I hit both of them
nice grouping ah yeah play together
let's get this [ __ ] come on go after
him together I know yes we gotta stick
we're an elite okay let me play some
more go for the head Hey I don't don't
beep the lane don't don't think the land
oh no I don't Pikachu the lane nice one
yeah right after you said metamorphic
the lane he just
[Music]
wasting my super beep where are you at
right there you guys go pink don't
venture too far so you not gonna come
around left here
sweaty cold area
oh my I can't be to survive he's dead
though okay four down four o'clock [ __ ]
cope got heavy over here I need help
he's right there he's right there watch
out one again well let's talk we're not
sticking together where they are if you
ever you see red go for it peek peek you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't hear you
[ __ ] [ __ ] though you still angry at
that tree from yesterday
[ __ ] you don't even think all that [ __ ]
you three feather
don't peek that's a team shot don't peek
peek five Shutterfly plenty of time to
fight watch out he's got shadi and he's
sitting back there and his [ __ ] rip
like that little I need help
Oh what is it see now I know what needs
to change if a shotgun is a one-shot
kill and can fire so fast a fusion rifle
ship fire faster absolutely not just
last forever
the fun last night
altered technology he's heard but
nobody's around you can really you shut
the [ __ ] up you passive-aggressive piece
of [ __ ] yeah if I'm getting killed
I'm where I'm supposed to be fighting
them you're off in a corner someplace no
we're not talking it out man what's
going on I'm right here with you Steve
we're not talking enough I'm right
behind you Steve they're gonna get heavy
over there on the left now you've left
three minutes this is what I'm saying
what happened guys wait wait hold on
hold on
it's two on three and one of the guys oh
my god okay where is this
Oh watch out Griffin he's got the
shotgun still don't run it boom boom
Steve got me nicely good job Steve
get that they're coming they're coming
again they're coming again coming
they're right there
yeah I just want to give both I don't
want to give both of them so I got both
of them and then I'm satisfied that's
something for everything so now it
doesn't matter so both of y'all check
them all I need them so that goes up
slam oh God
well there's morgues to be gotten if
they get all of us get those that get
that heavy get that heavy it's time God
you can pull it back we need four kills
let's stay together coming from behind
us yeah I got a rest back here people
[Music]
why did I shoot all right let's do let's
let's switch it up
Oh should we switch take Pikachu
ain't no coca tea really versus Griffin
mean and Craig wait just bounce down
just like there I yeah man oh man
he literally cranked get him back on
yeah how am I gonna get it back it on if
you look I was over there I'd [ __ ]
break into his house right now yeah get
that [ __ ] just that [ __ ] from clean one
game one [ __ ] game yeah
and calling them hot siculus I kind of
want to try something everybody already
knows it's speeding a red sign yeah my
[ __ ] date can't believe you left
after one
[Music]
all right so you want to just do well
now would you just go do a quick place
I'm look yeah yeah will do quickly I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna go to the
tower cuz I need to go to sir I haven't
gone dessert yet I don't think for for
what yeah he's at the tower he's next to
dead orbit most do you guys in my sights
you know what actually that's at the
ended you hit me with a bolt from that
whatever fusion you're using is a arc
yeah marking it yeah it got my risk
runner going dude you know it's cool
though section chain I just found out I
just found out that game Miller I was a
storm I was I was a storm caller I got
hit by some up something wondering you
guys's arc and they it's still propped
that risk runner I built it gave me a
shield over my storm collar
what's his file for it yeah
if it's risk run is the bee's knees man
I like this thing from my favorite
submachine gun just a risk runner have a
catalyst
yeah it does yeah you gotta get it right
I don't know it it's not I don't know
what it does okay
damnit we didn't get asked him about
Disneyland
[ __ ] yeah yeah we did get that mother
well dude I'm gonna call him yeah
Griffin supposed to ask him about this
anyway yeah the MS over there real quick
yeah go over there slap some sense into
you know I'm talking about desert
Steve's not gonna open his door you
should call him you said you're gonna
call him he'll answer if you call no
they buffed it they buffed it though
I'll stop my dragon shadow they changed
it now that he knows all your when I
already did this I already got this baby
peacemakers do you know that though
Griffin that dragon shadow reloads all
your weapons now yeah no I know but it's
an office worth use wouldn't their sons
well what's cool about it is like the
summe you can use the Dodge for the
mailing you know a nice old lady is
useless right now I mean in PvP the
Sungrazers are like you rarely get to do
that you know what I mean right so it's
probably better to use it I come bearing
help I thought why was is not my Ohana
is yours
thank you
yeah another thing a chance test while
sprinting a little bit speed is increase
in energy that's what I use
that's what I use I have a message for
you from the nine but oh you talk about
the luma fication boots be right back
right yeah no those are cool he's the
transversus steps because the
transversal Zoey
do not be afraid the nine we look at the
Luna vacation boots they made it so you
don't have to go in and out right it
just me loves if you are here it means
them like if you die what happens to
yourself your ghost cells
the heliosheath is not the only door
yeah there's on some [ __ ] onions that
has got tentacles coming out of his
[ __ ] face so if that doesn't tell you
something all right if Steve comes back
let's not do custom maps let's do
something live it's yeah yeah we'll do
like Craig meant to go I'm love him
Steve said wanted to work on my album
thanks Steve on a Sunday the day that we
planned all this yeah I know
I'm done huckleberries good to stevie is
such a diagonal conquers the one man
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] played one one game
come on we have we have to get him back
what are you what do you want me to do
nothing I can do if you know we're gonna
come back you gotta get him back dude
everyone hall meeting even Frank is
gonna get back get on he's on the way
home mm-hmm he wants to go work on his
album it's okay this is why we need to
have a conversation earlier and it
didn't happen come on we're gonna have
the meeting after this we'll call
yeah yeah let's just yeah one more you
got it and we can stop streaming and
then we'll we'll work on everything yeah
you got to include that Bobby stuff that
was too funny yeah
I was like he never just shows up that
that was weird that was so funny I don't
even know also fall out to do a new fall
out that book that's multiplayer a new
definitely better
we're definitely playing that yeah
that'll be cool you could probably get
Bobby to play with us I'm just kidding
well Stephen Bobby love follow Allah
yeah you do
yeah dude Bobby called you fat cheese
here we go not instigating and we just
paid on this man let's get it
no pun Seadrill char has to stop
dreaming why it's awesome that you're
all on right now yeah yeah it's awesome
need that we're gonna be on every Sunday
but we got to figure out prism to us the
next time mm-hmm I mean it sucks we
didn't get it working
butter was that
[Music]
traded there's all three of them in the
middle near work yeah I'm not going
through the bridge let's go up up team
shoot we know how to play this
we were just long as a man
goddammit man let's roll around them
like worth
yeah they don't get where I'm at right
now yeah I'm going work coax that
Sarlacc mental dude behind you behind
you yeah it's not gonna matter
whoa what what wow and you can kill by a
nameless midnight was time to quit
really jumped away guys but there's a
guy sitting back I got the one get off
to the side
yeah the guy sitting backwards the guy
that's driving me nuts
[Music]
I hate to learn about how did that guy
not Donna
that guy was one sniper so I'm gonna
tackle that hunt that guy god damn it he
[ __ ] threw down a rip [ __ ] [ __ ]
good kill these you know I need help no
I'm here okay that guy's lag
that's that's part of the problem that's
why I like I can't tell if that's dudes
like even getting hurt not for you [ __ ]
me three times before you shot it I know
are a team play from Craig
you mean coke
fireteam let's [ __ ] get it we can
bring it back [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
yeah
I got eros Oh hammer time
that's [ __ ] that Nova kills such
[ __ ] dude I'm past the guy in a clam
and it makes no sense how can they kill
me what I'm already past so hurt the
fact that he's got other guys watching
beside that peak
nice Pikachu's there's a guy's [ __ ]
skull anyway by the thing over there oh
we can beat these guys they're not that
nice Griffin I
there's gonna get away - [ __ ] no Coco
top Coco no the guy's lying these
[ __ ] are just [ __ ] stayin out
there
throw is the Hampton that's a time and
lag switchers I'm moving damn you know
where are you cutting my buying you
Wow that didn't even touch the other guy
from this solar day girls whatever
and I agree Mighty Max come follow
multiple beat oh yeah you'll definitely
see us playing that that's RPG yeah and
then to Arthur my gun is not starting
out that's what that means
[Music]
yeah 6939 learning [ __ ] it clearly you
gotta do one more tell you what what
session
let's go to bed after this and we'll
have our quick meeting yeah I'll go this
Steve get so long I will go walk over
there my phone what I'll do is I'll call
you coke so just put us up settling 3:30
a.m. and just 8:30 yeah I hope you live
stress are you working out again so
cyberpunk look dope you just say that in
a supportive way he could you all with
me to work out when he was here for five
minutes
good alright minutes I did the whole
workout what are you talking about he
went to my bootcamp was a good time
coke coke didn't like the guy
no the guy was called his name major
major him jay is cool oh no their exam
bro
yeah at the very end no yeah we start in
piquancy always starts oh supremacy
stage yes get him in here now how the
[ __ ] are you seeing him get on I don't I
never seen your Pony it's on getting set
up
I like this man
Aeryn pilot Pikachu because I think
we're on in private
let's get it okay I don't know why so
wait you're saying it is funnier than
what so still play it or what yeah yeah
did you just hit a ball yeah did Frank
come over yeah so Steve you want to hear
about this all right seems to just
connect together really it's gonna be
great
we've already falling behind be nice
you're in the lead and I'm with you
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
different how to do specialty don't they
give you I don't think my seller
let's so Steve
I'm trying to do it not enough time like
maybe you need to take a day and just go
work on it that's what I want to do I
just can't do that I don't know why I
don't know either
nice hello
always got her side
pretty pretty solid
alright well me up my eight guys careful
nice a nice left right
you know that's not all hey yes
twitching yeah yeah yeah 13 there's a
lot of people went away while we've been
playing this [ __ ] game it's fun
Huber's right now I turn it down I
turned it on you thank you thank you got
a yellow light oh we're gonna talk after
we're done
some guys said he loves your music
mister mister
I can play Sundays and we switch to
Sunday for you you play one [ __ ] game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]